hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm back with the 10th I believe
installment of this semi daily Q&A
series today's question is why does it
seem like records in powerlifting are
falling so quickly and so much faster
than they are in any other sport does
that tell us that our training methods
are just getting way way better so you
know what's going on here
so to address this question I think that
it's simply just a matter of probability
and athlete pool not that that explains
all of it but that probably explains
most of it so powerlifting in the past
five six years has really experienced
just an explosion in exposure and a huge
increase in the number of athletes
entering the sport coming from a few
different things one just how much more
information is getting put out about it
on the internet and how much easier it
is to come to I think YouTube has
probably had a lot to do with this a lot
of youtubers with really big audiences
have moved more from more just like
bodybuilding aesthetic type stuff to
more strength based stuff so that's
given powerlifting a lot of exposure
I think CrossFit is to thank for a lot
of it as well a lot of the new power
lifters I see getting into the sport
originally started with CrossFit and you
know decided that they liked the heavy
squats and deadlifts more than the met
cons weightlifting as well weightlifting
it was a lot to CrossFit with a huge
explosion in the athlete pool at least
in the US so I think that that probably
explains the majority of it if you just
start with the basic assumption that
human capability exists roughly along a
bell curve then whatever ability you
think the average person has and
whatever standard deviation you think
there is and if you
ability the more and more people there
are the the further and further you're
going to be able to get from the mean in
terms of standard deviations and the
people setting records are by definition
people who are many standard deviations
from the mean and just probabilistically
the larger population you have putting
into the putting into a sport the the
more standard deviations you should
expect to see in terms of performance so
you know if you just start with the
assumption that the average person after
years of good training may be capable of
a 300 blokes score I'm not necessarily
saying that's what I think I'm just
saying we'll start with that assumption
because it makes the numbers much easier
and let's say that the average person or
that the standard deviation in terms of
performance is about 50 whelps points so
about two thirds of people would fall
somewhere between 250 and 350 and for
people they don't know Wilkes Score is
the way that performance is normalized
taking body weight into account for
powerlifting so roughly you know you so
you can compare people in higher weight
classes and lower weight classes so okay
let's start with that assumption with a
pretty small population you know you may
expect to see plenty of people one
standard deviation from the mean maybe a
person or two two standard deviations
from the mean with a 400 Wilkes that
would be about two and a half percent of
the population within two standard
deviations about ninety-five percent of
people would fall so you would expect
about half of that five percent to be
out of 400 books or above so you know if
you have a population of a thousand
lifters in a sport you should expect to
find quite a few people two standard
deviations from the mean but probably
you would be very very unlikely to find
someone four standard deviations from
the mean with a 500 book score or some
of the best in the world are now
cracking as 600 books who are at least
getting very very close to it with a
population of a thousand lifters it
would be incredibly unlikely
to find someone that good then if you
make the population ten times bigger a
hundred times bigger regardless of how
much of an outlier you're talking about
it becomes much much more likely you're
going to stumble across one of those
people now you know if if you just
picked random people out of a population
and said like you know how is there
going to be a freak power lifter here it
very well could be that the first person
you picked just randomly was Edie cone
or Jessi Norris that's entirely possible
but it's very very unlikely and just
simply the larger population you're
working with the more likely it is that
you're going to find those freaks in
that population and now comparing
powerlifting to other sports why do you
see records fall even so often and so
quickly in powerlifting compared to
other sports a couple things there one
there are just more weight classes and
divisions I mean you know in terms of
like 100-meter sprint there is the
hundred meter sprint you have a male and
female division and you have I think
like some masters and submasters
divisions but there's there's one event
in powerlifting you have a ton of weight
classes you have you know submasters
1-2-3 Junior teen masters police fire
military like there are a ton of
divisions for records to be set you also
have different standards of competition
single ply for all role with knee wraps
so that gives you many more
opportunities for records to be set but
then also even if we're gonna mix all of
that and just talk about say IPF World
Records or all-time World Records or
anything like that you're still dealing
you're still dealing with more classes
but also you're dealing with a younger
sport and going back to the original
point you're dealing with a sport that's
currently experiencing an explosion in
exposure and athlete pool so you know
there's there's probably not that large
of a difference in terms of people
competing in marathons today versus ten
years ago but they're probably well
there
definitely is for powerlifting there are
many more people powerlifting now than
there were five ten years ago so that's
something that I mean every sport goes
through it but right now that is the
point in life in empower liftings
lifespan where it's at so you should
expect to see records to follow much
more frequently and so that's probably
the main thing going on it is certainly
possible that training methods have
improved that maybe nutrition has
improved all of those things could
factor in but if you're looking for what
is probably fueling the majority of the
increases in performance you're seeing
at the top levels the amount of records
that are falling it is probably just
that the athlete pool has gotten so much
bigger and so probabilistically you're
much much more likely to come across
very very high performers we're going to
be better than everyone else and push
the records a little bit further so that
is the video if you liked it please like
and subscribe
and if you have questions about you know
lifting training sports science really
anything kind of in that realm that you
want answered ask them in the comments
below and if it is my favorite I will
pick it and answer it in the next video
alright until next time hope your
training is good hope you have a great
day and I will see you in the next video